what were your thoughts coming from the
culture here in L.A
when you see this quando Rondo kid go on
Instagram and say driving his flag he's
dropping his flag
I felt like it's usually not that easy
right man [ __ ] don't work like that [ __ ]
damn man ain't born in this [ __ ] [ __ ]
you talking about dropping your flag hey
get off the end and get off the internet
and go do what you need to do and I'm
talking about anybody that think this
gang banging this [ __ ] is easy man
listen ain't nobody bigger than the
program see the fact is you get money
you think you're bigger than the program
you're not you still got rules and
regulations that you got to go by it's
still somebody that I got to answer to
regardless if I got millions
right and he's not even he's not from
here so I think he probably don't even
understand like what he really signed up
for you don't know what you signed and
that's the problem with these artists
when people be like oh well
oh well six nine he ain't this he didn't
know man that man was caught man listen
you know what you sign up for
taking on the chin get in the field and
get ready like that's why I don't I
don't come here and say because the fans
ain't like I'm like Joe Moses still
promoting gang banging it no you're not
I'm just telling you the real I know
what I signed up for every day when I
walk outside if I go to a restaurant and
eat with my family and somebody see me
over there I know what I signed up for
Angel hey man this [ __ ] Joe Mo's up
here eating with his family come up here
like that [ __ ] like that happened so you
got to be prepared for everything that
you signed up for and I know when I'm
coaching football bro I'm I'm I I know
what I signed up for I just can't be
just forgetful of what happened in my
past and like oh I'm just coaching
football and nobody won't come and be
sitting down the street and waiting for
me to pull off and and bust 12 shots
into my car and try to kill me like bro
you have to know what you signed up for
this [ __ ] I don't think people really
understand what they trying to rap and
they trying to be from a section and
they think they get money and they think
they bigger than the program ain't no
man bigger than the program like
nobody's bigger than the pro I don't
care if you got 30 million bro you're
not bigger than the program bro you
still gotta answer to somebody it's
still little homies over there that's
making sure that you able to still come
over here so what you gonna do and I
don't and I'm and not to say it like
that I don't even associate myself
with with negativity I associate myself
with all positivity first and foremost
you know what I'm saying but I know what
I signed up for I love my homies win
lose a draw you know what I'm saying I'm
never gonna come up here and talk bad
about my homies and my section I'm never
gonna be like oh I got money and them
[ __ ] can't I love my homies like at
certain points in my life sometimes I
just separate myself and just do my own
thing that don't mean I don't love my
hood right I love my homies that just
mean I'm just oh I'm on my grind I'm on
my Grizzy I'm on my game I'm trying to
I'm trying to make it make it I'm not
trying to be having businesses I'm
trying to make it like puffy like Jay-Z
and I'm not trying to be no trying to
halfway make it or like neighborhood
make it or else I'm not trying I'm
trying to be worldwide successful like
you know what I'm saying owning my own
liquor and doing my own thing and and
and and I say a person that made it that
a person won't even look look at to like
we we say Jay-Z and we say puffy right
I'm trying to make it like Snoop I'm
trying to make it like E40 40 got his
own liquor killing him he's got his own
liquor he's got his own ice cream he has
his own lumpia company come on bro he's
got like I just don't look up to his
wine he's got the [ __ ] Turf burritos
I just don't look up to them Staples
because like I say I was born and raised
where nine to five was special like you
know what I'm saying like everybody got
their Lane of how you supposed to do
stuff my grandfather who worked like I
still look up to him like you don't got
to have be successful and have a job and
I mean we're making million dollars for
me not to look at you taking care of
your family is successful for me and
that's my main that's my main goal you
know what I'm saying